bonjour à tous bienvenue c'est l'ère de
parlement hebdo 45 minutes pour faire le
tour de l'actualité politique et
parlementaire cette semaine dans
l'actualité avec nous katia
bonjourbonjour nickel le début d'un long
marathon pour la loi travail examinés et
votés en commission à l'assemblée
nationale
dans le même temps syndicats étudiants
et lycéens poursuivent les
manifestations et le parlement a voté la
loi qui pénalise les clients de
prostituées c'est la fin d'un long
chemin parlementaire et d'un long
feuilleton entre le sénat et l'assemblée
le renouveau en politique a le vent en
poupe emmanuel macron a beaucoup
réfléchi dit-il il lance un nouveau
mouvement nommé en marche ni de droite
ni de gauche
et on va parler de tout ça avec notre
invité cette semaine guillaume larrivé
bonjour bonjour vous êtes député les
républicains de l'yonne et porte-parole
de votre parti on va commenter cette
semaine avec vous on commence bien sûr
avec le début du marathon le début et
même la foire du marathon parlementaire
lundi et toute la semaine les députés
ont voté en commission la loi elle
conneries et le texte a donc été réécrit
à la faveur de plus de mille amendements
déposés par me et les dispositions
votées le référendum d'entreprise le
compte personnel d'activités aussi un
assouplissement du licenciement
économique compte rendu de la dernière
séance en commission avec rennes
benameur l'article 30 c'est le fameux
article sur la redéfinition du
licenciement économique
l'article le plus contesté de cette loi
désormais le licenciement pourrait être
justifiée par une baisse des commandes
ou du chiffre d'affaires ou tout autre
motif justifiant ces difficultés et les
décisions seraient plus difficilement
contestable devant les tribunaux c'est
l'analyse des frondeurs qui demande le
retrait de l'article
en effet il ya une idée qui est porté
par ceux qui pensent que ce texte en
tout cas cet article est la base
nécessaire dans le code du travail pour
régler une partie du problème de
compétitivité créer de l'emploi
moi je considère avec d'autres que c'est
une idée et rené avec pour conséquence
un recul de la protection des salariés
mais le rapporteur veut équilibrer le
texte avec un geste en direction des pme
il propose un amendement visant à
distinguer le nombre de trimestres de
baisse de l'activité selon la taille de
l'entreprise
l'amendement que je vous propose intègre
la baisse des commandes ou du chiffre
d'affaires en soit en comparaison avec
la même période de l'année précédente
d'au moins un trimestre pour les
entreprises de moins de onze salariés
d'au moins deux trimestres consécutifs
pour les entreprises entre 11 et 50 d'au
moins trois trimestres pour les
entreprises de 50 à 300 et enfin de -4
trimestre pour les plus de 300 salariés
une méthode contestée par la droite
on arrive aujourd'hui à une nouvelle
modification de ceux de ce texte qui est
alors c'est pas forcément une reculade
pour une fois mais c'est quand même une
façon d'interpréter des choses qui est
totalement différente malgré ses
craintes
l'article 30 a été adopté bon alors ce
texte a en effet été adopté en
commission s'est pas pour autant la fin
du parcours
est ce que vous êtes satisfait de la
réécriture du texte
non non parce que là la machine à
rigidité socialiste tourne à plein
régime
on voit bien on a compris au départ un
avant projet de texte assez ambitieux et
puis ensuite un texte qui devient on
sait qu'ensuite la rose socialiste
oui mais très concrètement il faut que
nous les républicains les députés avec
isabelle le callennec j'ai un champion
ou les sénateurs ici avec notamment jean
baptiste lemoyne
il faut qu'on fasse évidemment notre
travail d'amendements et sur des choses
très concret le travail parlementaire
c'est être utile ces amendements ont été
tous rejetés en commission par les
socialistes à l'assemblée cette semaine
y refuse par exemple qu'on supprime le
monopole des syndicats pour les
candidatures dans les entreprises
ils refusent la suppression des seuils
sociaux qui bloque l'emploi dans les pme
y refuse un vrai barème des indemnités
prud'homales en cas de licenciement bref
sur tous les sujets concrets on semble
redonner de l'oxygène
les socialistes nous disent niet nada
ils n'en veulent pas ils sont en train
de préparer un texte classique mancelle
refusé alors que ont fait bouffer le
travail parlementaire ont fait des
propositions on est à l'écouté des
besoins du terrain on vous sait ce que
les entreprises françaises ont besoin
c'est à dire de plus de souplesse de
plus de liberté pour encourager tous
ceux qui veulent créer qui veulent
progresser qui veulent avancer
et puis on se heurte à un mur le mur n'a
parti socialiste complètement ringard
qui refusent ces avancées concrètes pour
les entreprises voilà la réalité
tout n'est pas à jeter dans ce texte
création du compte an et par le temps
qui permet d'être payés quand vous ne
prenez pas de congés il ya quand même
des et dispositifs nous apprenons par
cet exemple le comte d'activité que dans
la loi elle comrie bon c'est bien gentil
mais ils maintiennent le comte
pénibilité ça c'est une absurdité compte
pénibilité il entre en vigueur
ces jours-ci notamment dans les
entreprises du bâtiment et des travaux
publics
c'est un nid à ennuis pour ne pas dire
autre chose pour les entreprises et donc
ça détruit de l'emploi
moi je souhaiterais que on entre enfin
dans le concret et que très très très
très utilement de manière très simple
très pragmatique on prenne les 10-15
mesure de déverrouillage de ces
contraintes qui empêchent aujourd'hui
les pme d'embauché vous dites que le
débat parlementaire telle qu'elle est
menée actuellement ne permet pas pour
vous d'exprimer nos rangs parce qu'il ya
une réalité la majorité des députés
socialistes qui ont été lus il ya
bientôt quatre ans maintenant juin 2012
sont sur une ligne qui n'est pas une
ligne réformiste c'est pas une ligne pro
entreprise c'est une ligne plutôt aubry
ce taux mélenchon aux nostalgiques
c'est quasiment la ligne du 19e siècle
je dirais c'est mais vraiment c'est
frappant faut écouter comme ce qu'il dit
dans les débats de commission des
affaires sociales à l'assemblée
c'est pas du tout c'est plus une gauche
moderne argent je pense qu'il ya
décalage en tout cas entre les besoins
des entreprises et cette majorité
socialiste qui me paraît complètement à
la ramasse et complètement décalé par
rapport aux besoins de la france de 2016
des entreprises 2016
alors on en reparlera 3 mai le texte
arrive dans l'hémicycle en attendant la
semaine a été aussi marquée par les
révélations de cas d'évasion fiscale à
grande échelle scandale planétaire
panama papers c'est le nom de l' enquête
internationale conduite par une centaine
de journaux à la permis de dévoiler une
liste de propriétaires d'avoir au panama
payré inscrit depuis sur la liste des
paradis fiscaux germain andrieu une
enquête planétaire sur plus de 11
millions de documents
tous sont issus du cabinet d'avocats
panaméen maussac fonséca plus de 140
responsables politiques et personnalités
seraient concernés dans le monde
françois hollande a déjà annoncé pour
les cas français
des répliques judiciaire immédiate ces
informations ces révélations confirment
qu'il est possible de lutter contre la
fraude fiscale et toutes les
informations qui seront livrés donneront
lieu à des enquêtes des services fiscaux
et à des procédures judiciaires
les montages de comptes offshore peuvent
être légaux mais à une condition
les déclarés auprès du fisc français
sinon tout fraudeur fiscal risque une
amende et une peine d'emprisonnement
il ya déjà des poursuites aujourd'hui
engagée contre un certain nombre des
personnes qui ont déjà été nommés à la
suite de ces révélations
toute autre personne qui viendrait à
notre connaissance sera poursuivie par
les voies légales
parce que comme vous l'avez dit la
fraude fiscale est insupportable plus
encore aujourd'hui au moment où beaucoup
de français sont dans la difficulté le
gouvernement du panama a de son côté
confirmé sa coopération avec la justice
en cas d'ouverture d'une procédure
judiciaire
le gouvernement s'était engagé à lutter
contre contre ces dérives
et comme le dit michel sapin il a eu
quand même des résultats vous les
reconnaissez une certaine efficacité en
ce domaine
non mais je suis pas là pour distribuer
des bons points à ce gouvernement non
pardon enfin ce que je constate d'abord
sérieusement c'est que la liberté de la
presse et de la liberté de la presse
d'investigation permet
de mettre dans le débat public des
informations qui sont extrêmement
intéressante et tant mieux et je tiens
beaucoup à ça et chattes liberté
d'investigation le secret des sources
également c'est quelque chose de très
important de connaître les auteurs
notent démocrate budget qui dit qu' il
aurait bien aimé que la presse puisse
lui donner ces listings en tout cas je
constate qu'ils sont dans le débat
public maintenant chacun doit prendre
ses responsabilités
il faut que l'autorité judiciaire selon
les procédures qui sont les siennes
c'est à dire un vrai sérieux d' enquête
d'investigation certain nombre aussi de
respect des droits de la défense de
contradictoire de secret de
l'instruction bref que tout ça
fonctionne et que toute la lumière soit
faite sur ces manquements ce que je
voudrais aussi ajouter c'est qu'il ya
évidemment des paradis fiscaux
c'est pas bien mais ce n'est pas bien
aussi c'est l'enfer fiscal dans lequel
se trouve un certain nombre de nos
compatriotes et je veux parler des
classes moyennes qui sont pas du tout
naturellement pas contre les classes de
justin de aussi mais ça veut dire
quelque chose c'est la fiscalité
parce que ya effectivement ces paradis
fiscaux et des systèmes de détournement
qui sont complètement scandaleux avec de
la fraude fiscale et puis parallèlement
il ya des français des artisans des
commerçants des salariés des familles
qui n'en peuvent plus de l'enfer fiscal
français limougeaude 9 commise à son
doigt fait alors ce qu'elle doit faire
non non pas du tout ça va l'artisan de
toucy ou de saint fargeau dans ma
circonscription il a pas un conte au
panama contrairement peut-être à
monsieur cahuzac ou à des gens
effectivement de la nomenclature à
socialistes françaises qui ont utilisé
ces systèmes en 2009 nicolas sarkozy qui
disait les paradis fiscaux se terminer
c'est tromper quand même et on est en
2016 non oui je crois qu'il est pas
présent de la république il a été
commandé interrogé peut-être vais-je
roland d'accord mais aujourd'hui c'est
françois hollande le président de la
république française karine bloch 2011
la liste de panama qui revient
aujourd'hui beaucoup de choses on être
mis sur liste noire avait beaucoup de
choses ont été faites lors du
quinquennat précédent pour essayer
notamment à l'échelle du g20 de faire
entendre la voix de la france est ce que
je regrette c'est que depuis plusieurs
années la voix de la france sur la scène
internationale elle est complètement
inaudible
il n'y a pas une initiative française à
bruxelles quand vous allez à bruxelles
discuter avec la commission ou quand
vous allez à berlin je les fais à la fin
du mois de janvier
échanger avec le cd ou ce qu'on vous dit
à
côté français c'est que le gouvernement
français il est inaudible et sur cette
question là aussi savez c'est très bien
de faire des discours de meeting comme
le parti socialiste et le faire ça
aurait été mieux de prendre des
initiatives à l'échelle du g20 à
l'échelle peut-être aussi de la banque
mondiale pour lutter efficacement à
concrètement contre ces détournements et
les paradis fiscaux guillaume larrivé va
changer un petit peu de sujets c'est
mardi toujours le premier ministre qui a
coutume du parler vrai il faut le dire à
désigner clairement son adversaire c'est
l'islam radical
manuel valls a relancé le débat sur la
place du salafisme aux france écoutez il
ya une forme de minorité agissante des
groupes qui sont en train de gagner à la
dalle dans d'autres temps on aurait dit
de la bataille de logique culturelle les
salafis doivent représenter 1%
aujourd'hui des musulmans de notre pays
mais leur message
mais comment juger l'auteur un jeune et
messages sur les réseaux sociaux et dans
le débat culturel
il n'y a qu'une certaine manière qu'on
entend et il ya un lien que pardon qui
se font entendre en plus pour les jeunes
parce que la parole de l'islam de france
unie aujourd'hui n'est pas toi la raison
manuel valls vous auriez pu tenir ce
propos je donne crédit à manuel valls
d'une sincérité dans cet engagement et
je suis convaincu pour ma part que nous
devons sur cette question faire l'union
de tous les républicains de tous les
patriotes contre l'islamisme parce que
l'islamisme est notre ennemi l'islamisme
nous a déclaré une forme de guerre
l'islamisme veut détruire la société
française telle qu'elle est une société
liberté une société d'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes
je pense que le devoir de tous les
républicains de tous les patriotes des
diverses rives du débat public
c'est effectivement l'unité mais surtout
l'efficacité contre ce danger qui nous
menace et donc il faut maintenant qu'on
soit dans les actes et qu'on soit
extrêmement efficace et concret pour
lutter concrètement partout en france
contre cet ennemi islamistes certes mais
pour le conseil français du culte
musulman ce type de propos est assez
exagéré il divise en trois grandes de
cidre a marre là je connais bien le
président du cfcm à new york et bi belge
il avait tort de s'exprimer ainsi au
contraire d'une menace fantasme est
exagéré pour vous mais pas du tout
écouté il suffit hélas d'ouvrir un
magazine où il suffit
se rendre dans de nombreux quartiers de
france pour bien constater que cette
menace allait pas fantasmer et pardon de
devoir le dire aussi
mais ça n'est pas un fantasme et
attentat islamiste c'est quelque chose
qui nous a meurtri dans notre chère je
voudrais vous faire une proposition à
votre en plaine je propose qu'on bouge
le la loi sur un sujet très précis je
souhaite que désormais les autorisations
de construction de mosquées en matière
d'urbanisme ne soit pas décidée
seulement par les nerfs mais en
codécision par le ministre de
l'intérieur et par le maire parce que je
pense qu'il faut à la fois qu'ils aient
une instruction locale ça c'est le maire
avec notamment des considérations
d'urbanisme les considérations
d'acceptation par la population locale
mais il faut aussi un vrai contrôle
policier un vrai contrôle d'ordre public
pour savoir qui paye qui finance la
mosquée qui va prêcher
quel va être le contenu des princes il
est nécessaire d'avoir désormais c'est
vraiment une annonce que je vous fais un
copilotage ministère de l'intérieur mary
une co décision sur cette question
extrêmement sensible de l'autorisation
de construction des mosquées ans qu'est
ce que vous pensez que les institutions
représentatives notamment pour les
musulmans seraient d'accord
je ne sais pas mais c'est au parlement
d'en décider car d'après nous y habituer
c'est nous députés qui représentons
l'ensemble de la nation je représente 1
500 77e des français qu'il s'agisse de
français qui croient au ciel qui n'y
croient pas nos français catholique de
français musulmans de france et qui sont
à tête france agnostique nous
représentons tous les français vous en
france il ya un problème avec la
construction de mosquées
il ya manifestement un problème d'ordre
public avec un certain nombre de
structures qui existent déjà qu'il faut
fermer parce qu'il faut fermer toutes
les mosquées salafistes qui menace
l'ordre public et il faut aussi veiller
à ne pas construire n'importe quoi
n'importe comment
j'ai moi même un contentieux avec le
maire d'auxerre dans ma ville mon chef
de l'opposition je m'oppose à la
construction d'une mosquée pour laquelle
je m'interroge dollars issus des cités
par rapport à cette proposition que vous
avez déposé un texte jj travail au plan
au plan juridique n'est en tout cas
c'est l'orientation que je me suis que
je me suis fonctionnaire je pense qu'il
faut modifier la règle de droit est
donné ce pouvoir de codécision au
ministre de l'intérieur pour des raisons
d'ordre public
vous avez peut-être pas les clubistes
intérieur d'amour et après on passer à
d'autres sujets c'est un sujet sur
lequel nous devons progresser ensemble
d'accords de voir passer au projet de
réforme pénale qui a été voté au sénat
c'est un projet qui a été fait après les
attentats notamment à qui ont secoué le
13 novembre dans des paris ce texte
prévu pour prendre le relais de l'état
d'urgence a été approuvé par une très
forte majorité
il prévoit la perpétuité réelle ou les
perquisitions nocturnes et des usages
aussi des armes approfondies notamment
pour les forces de l'ordre vous êtes
satisfait de ce texte pour l'essentiel
c'est un bon taxe gelé votée à
l'assemblée je l'avais amendé notamment
j'avais fait voter les amendements
quelques mois sur jean jacques urvoas
un amendement sur la perpétuité
incompressible pour les criminels
terroristes dont on a un peu parlé qui a
été repris ici au sénat j'ai une ou deux
réserves notamment sur le visage ou le
dit de limousis catcheurs en matière en
matière judiciaire ont fait remonter un
certain point relativement technique les
services qui utilise évidemment pour je
suis totalement favorable à sauver
utilise dans le cadre des services de
renseignement et on a voté une loi dont
j'étais le co-rapporteur en 2015
à cet égard je suis pas complètement
convaincu que cet instrument doivent
être utilisés par la police judiciaire
de droit commun si j'ose dire mais sous
cette réserve qui est presque une nuance
techniquement fin qui fait tu peux faire
débat globalement c'est un texte utile
qui va dans la bonne direction parce que
c'est un texte c'est un texte très
pragmatique en réalité exemple c'est
tout à fait nécessaire qu'on puisse
retenir pendant quatre heures un
individu pour une vérification
d'identité approfondie si on avait eu
cet outil on aurait peut-être laissé on
aurait peut-être évité de laisser
échapper
plus précisément abdeslam au soir du 13
novembre lorsqu'il a été contrôlé qui
n'a pas été identifié vous pensez que
soit résolu cette affaire au haut du
corps le cassage de l'ulam je cite cet
exemple précis une retenue de quatre
heures qui n'est pas une garde à vue et
qui est plus qu un contrôle d'identité
lambda c'est absolument indispensable
et au cas particulier je le dis aussi
comme vice présidents des commissions d
enquête sur les moyens de la lutte anti
terrorisme aucun particulier je crois
que ça aurait été utile vous dites que
ce texte qui va donc s'appliquer lorsque
la france sera sortie de l'état
d'urgence est donc complet et va donner
aux forces
le bolide à prétention de considérer que
ce sont des textes qu'on pense que c'est
un bon texte qui sera utile nous ne
faisons pas de cathédrales législatives
il faut être très volontariste et très
modeste
différents instruments juridiques mais
je constate voilà que c'est un texte qui
est assez utile il faut le compléter par
d' autres volets et notamment je reste
très attaché une idée très simple c'est
que un détenu condamné pour des faits de
terrorisme ne doit pas bénéficier du
même régime d'aménagement et d'exécution
des peines qu'un détenu ou qu'un l'homme
d'inception
j'avais fait un rapport parlementaire il
ya quelques mois qui révélait que 56
détenus terroristes condamnés ont fait
l'objet de mesures de libération
anticipée en 2012 2013 2014 quand
christiane taubira team usa justice ça
c'est pas possible il faut absolument
qu'on supprime les mécanismes de
réduction et d'aménagement de peine pour
les détenus terroristes
et là dessus on a un désaccord avec jean
jacques urvoas parce qu'il n'est pas en
accord avec cette proposition alors on
parle d'une autre réforme qui revient à
l'assemblée celle du conseil supérieur
de la magistrature qui est chargé
d'assister le président de la république
dans sa fonction de garant de
l'indépendance des juges le premier
texte présenté a été vidé de sa
substance par les sénateurs objectif
renforcer l'indépendance du parquet
germain andrieu c'est la seule réforme
qui pourrait encore réunir le congrès la
réforme du csm
le conseil supérieur de la magistrature
l'objectif a minima du garde des sceaux
et du gouvernement renforcer
l'indépendance du parquet en inscrivant
dans la constitution la nomination des
magistrats sur l'avis conforme du csm
on veut que aujourd'hui les justes ne
soient plus nommés par le pouvoir
politique
on fait une réforme a minima certes
peut-être mais en tout cas on fait une
vraie réforme appartiennent au président
la république de juger si les trois
cinquièmes sont possiblement rassemble
abl si c'est pas le cas les républicains
porteront encore la responsabilité
d'avoir
ou d'imaginer une justice aux ordres
quant à l'opposition
eric ciotti plusieurs députés
républicains veulent aller plus loin ils
réclament l'interdiction du syndicalisme
dans la magistrature
quand il y à des dérives et des
dérapages aussi important que celui
qu'on a pu constater son allure des cons
sans aucune conséquence d'ailleurs bien
le débat n'a pas été ouvert donc je
pense que c'est important en tout cas
qu'on en discute directement visé le
syndicat de la magistrature dénonce un
faux combat idéologique une mesure
inapplicable véritable enjeu c'est que
l'assemblée nationale le parlement dans
son ensemble se saisit d'une vraie
réforme du csm qui permettrait
d'accoître d'accroître l'indépendance
des magistrats sans aucune obligation
le gouvernement respecte aujourd'hui
l'avis du conseil supérieur de la
magistrature
une pratique qui devrait perdurer avant
d'être grave et peut-être un jour dans
la constitution
est-ce que vous souhaitez que cette
réforme du csm soit menée à son terme
soit voté avant la saint glinglin il ya
une gigantesque hypocrisie dans ce débat
le gouvernement vient vers nous en
disant indépendance indépendance
mais en réalité il nous soumet un texte
qui maintient le monopole de
présentation c'est à dire le choix des
candidats au parquet dans les mains du
garde des sceaux j'ai démontré sa avec
georges fenech et philippe houillon face
à jean-jacques urvoas dans la nuit de
mardi à mercredi à l'assemblée
il ya la vie conforme sas et en aval
c'est à la fin du dispositif mais en
amont il ya la présentation des
candidats qui vont devenir procureur et
ça ça reste dans les mains du garde des
sceaux donc c'est une gigantesque
hypocrisie ce texte même du point de vue
de l'indépendance de la justice
nenê n'est pas conforme à ses objectifs
par ailleurs à voter sur un rail a alors
été demandé aux sénateurs que ron stream
comme député je considère ce texte n'est
pas un bon texte parce que procède aussi
d'une véritable erreur d' analyse
l'indépendance de la justice pour moi et
pour mes collègues députés républicains
c'est l'impartialité des jugements ça
n'est pas l'autonomie d'un contre
pouvoir
judith
hier et donc on a une vraie divergence
d'approché je considère michael ça mais
ce que pour renforcer l'impartialité des
jugements il ya beaucoup de choses à
faire il faut revoir par contre la
formation de l'école nationale de la
magistrature
je m'interroge sur la multiplicité des
grades au sein de la magistrature
je m'interroge sur les décorations qui
sont aujourd'hui qu'il avait prononcé
quand même hallucinant qu'un
gouvernement décor ou ne dépend pas de
la légion d'honneur ou du mérite tel ou
tel magistrat nantais en cause quelque
part l'indépendance je considère
qu'avoir renforcer l'impartialité des
jugements je ne suis pas favorable à la
suppression de tout engagement syndical
mais pardon d'être un peu subtil mais
c'est parfaitement compréhensible
je considère qu'il peut y avoir la
défense d'intérêts professionnels
en revanche il peut pas y avoir une
expression politique et donc il faut qu
on recadre l'exercice de l'engagement
brain chrysler la droite ne votera pas
ce texte à l'assemblée nationale à
l'assemblée nationale nous avons déjà
rejeté l'article 1er l'article 2 de
cette réforme dans la nuit de mardi à
mercredi et le 26 avril lors du vote
solennel les députés républicains je
vous l'annoncé vous le confirme voteront
contre ce projet de loi
constitutionnelle ce qui veut dire d'eau
qu'il n'y aura pas de congrès ça c'est
au président de la république la réforme
de la constitution en aval epamsa du
scion garde mais j'imagine qu'il n'y
aura pas de majorité pour affaiblir
l'état car en france c'est ça la
question de fond c'est une révision
constitutionnelle qui loin de renforcer
l'état de droit
de mon point de vue la sebli c'est une
réforme incomplète qui s'adresse à une
partie d'un tout qui devrait être
réformé que vous autres jours de tête la
gauche aujourd'hui qui vous dit vous
n'avez pas fait la réforme des langues
régionales vous ne voulez pas de là des
choses nationalité maintenant le c5
voulait rien quoi pardon mais je les
renvoie à leurs propres turpitudes
lorsque nicolas sarkozy il ya quelques
années en 2008 a fait une révision de la
constitution pour donner de nouveaux
droits aux citoyens avec notamment la
qpc la possibilité pour chaque citoyenne
cl conseil constitionnel la gauche a
refusé lorsque nicolas sarkozy à
réformer le conseil super de la
magistrature savait avant nicolas
sarkozy c'était le président de la
république il présidait le csm
après nicolas sarkozy c'est plus le
président de la république la gauche
s'est opposée à cela alors vraiment j'ai
aucune leçon de morale républicaine
et d'indépendance de la justice à
recevoir de ces gens qui par ailleurs
ont un corps at il ya deux positions
assez déplorable passer aux mercredis
vous allez valais les députés aussi
planche sur l'élection présidentielle et
sur ce texte cette fois les républicains
ont voté en tout cas vous avez voté
c'est une proposition de loi organique
de modernisation des règles pour
l'élection présidentielle revoir les
règles de parrainage du temps de parole
vous imaginez aussi peut-être la colère
de ce que l'on appelle les plus petits
candidats écouter l'un d'entre eux
s'appelle nicolas dupont aignan et à
volonté c'est de supprimer le premier
tour en fait ils veulent faire
disparaître le 1er tour est enfermé les
français dans le tripartisme on a vu le
résultat aux régionales 20 millions
d'abstention plus d'un million de
bulletins nuls
c'est un cri ou vraiment contre la
démocratie au moment où la france va si
mal on refuse l'égalité du temps de
parole pendant cinq semaines
vous avez commis un crime contre la
démocratie si je comprends bien j'ai
voté oui sans aucune difficulté je te
demande a expliqué on demande l'avis de
votre groupe 1 où on en a débattu
rentrer nous vous savez on a toujours
une très grande liberté on n'est pas
capitalisé j'ai voté oui pourquoi parce
que je considère qu' il n'est pas normal
que jacques cheminade qui veut coloniser
la planète mars et le même temps de
parole au moment de l'élection
présidentielle que le chef de l'état
nicolas sarkozy ou françois hollande
aujourd'hui considère que l'élection
présidentielle quelque chose de trop
sérieuse consiste à choisir le chef de
l'état s'agit pas de donner une
exposition médiatique à n'importe quel
1-1 pardonnez moi et donc je trouve que
recadrer un peu l'exercice est tout à
fait sain deuxièmement la publicité des
parrainages c'est quelque chose de
profondément démocratique
lorsqu'on est maire lorsqu'on est
présente conseil général lorsqu'on est
parlementaire et qu'on s'engage pour un
candidat à la présidentielle c'est
normal qu'on dise publiquement et que
les citoyens tout simplement en ait
connaissance donc c'est une loi
transparente qui va dans le bon sens et
j'ai eu aucune difficulté à la voter
alors mercredi toujours la france a
rejoint le camp des pays européens qui
sanctionne les clients prostituées après
un ultime vote des députés le parlement
a définitivement adopté la proposition
de loi ps qui renforce la lutte contre
la prostitution la fin de deux ans et
demi
de bataille parlementaire la proposition
de loi instaure donc la pénalisation des
clients est ce que vous vous félicitez
de cette loi ce que c'est une loi de
progrès pour vous je ne crois pas et
d'ailleurs je n'ai pas pris part au vote
en conscience
j'étais très hésitant je vous dis hein
tout ce qui renforce les droits des
femmes naturellement doit être
encouragée en même temps pour en avoir
discuté avec un certain nombre de
collègues députés qui ont beaucoup
travaillé sur ce texte je suis pas
convaincu de son efficacité
voilà je suis pas convaincu j'en ai
parlé aussi parlé avec patrice ribeiro
un des responsables de syndicats
policiers qui explique que ça va être
extrêmement compliqué pour les policiers
de terrain d'appliquer ce texte ils ont
beaucoup de sujets à traiter
naturellement dans le genre d'évolution
je suis je ne suis pas sûr que c'est un
texte aussi aussi pertinent que certains
le pensent
voilà et je crains surtout que c'est un
texte qui au bout du bout changera
quasiment rien aux pratiques actuelles
alors la gauche est revenu sur un texte
qui avait été à l'époque voté par
nicolas sarkozy si vous revenez aux
affaires en 2017
est-ce que vous abrogerait ce texte ce
texte là il faudra l'évaluer il faudra
les vagues l'ufc on n'a jamais de
position idéologique sur aucun texte sur
ce que je veux dire c'est que il faut
parfois accepter l'idée qu'on évalue
l'effet d'une loi cette loi et vient
d'être votée elle est même pas publié au
journal officiel
elle a pas eu un début de commencement
d'application et vous me demandez si on
va à l'abroger en l'occurrence sur ce
sujet là qu'un sujet bien compliqué sauf
qu'il faudra évaluer sont en effet et
puis il y aura les restaurer ou qui va
un petit peu plus loin que ça c'est à
dire cette semaine nicolas sarkozy les
rythmes scolaires on abroge la réforme
du collège forme du canado va vous les
débuts par la gauche
aujourd'hui vous ne bougez pas du tout
alors tout à l'heure je vous ai dit
michaël szames est d'ailleurs je vous ai
dit que j'ai voté avec sérieux et
détermination et réflexion la loi sur la
procédure pénale présenté par jacques
urvoas donc pas partisan qu'on la
brochure aux affaires en revanche la
réforme du collège
oui concrètement quand vous nous
échanger avec des parents d'élèves des
professeurs de collège vous avez
conscience que ça ne marche pas les
enseignements pluridisciplinaires
r pratique ça marche pas on n'a pas
besoin de faire du collage pour
expérience l'histoire romaine
je crois que c'est vraiment quelque
chose qui est complètement à côté de la
plaque et la réforme du collège de près
par najat vallaud-belkacem
elle est pas bonne et il faudra
effectivement qu'on la broche pour
revenir à des fondamentaux l'école le
collège ça doit d'abord transmettre des
savoirs
ça doit pas faire des ateliers pâte à
modeler en 6e - 5e à ce jeudi voilà avec
emmanuel macro qui est en marche
il dit avoir beaucoup réfléchi emmanuel
macron à lancer un nouveau mouvement
politique qui s'appelle donc en marche
regarde j'ai consulté j'ai associé
beaucoup de gens et j'ai décidé qu'on
allait créer un mouvement politique un
mouvement politique use emmanuel macron
se met en marche
mercredi soir au palais des congrès
d'amiens sa ville natale il annonce la
création de son propre mouvement
politique un mouvement qu'il souhaite au
dessus des partis pouvaient être membre
du parti socialiste ait adhéré en marche
pouvait être membre des républicains
aient adhéré en marche ou membre d'un
autre parti républicain
les réactions n'ont pas tardé à droite
certains lui réservent un très bon
accueil
je ne vois aucune incompatibilité entre
emmanuel macron et alain juppé juppé
macron c'est le ticket de 2017
il ya quelque chose qui est intéressant
à creuser dans cette direction vers un
axe juppé macron à la prochaine
présidentielle
pas de précipitation pour ses collègues
du gouvernement
l'initiative pour être au contraire
servir la cause de françois hollande en
permettant au président d'aller chercher
des voix au centre
mais le trublion ministre entend
sûrement rassembler bien au-delà de ces
deux formations alors j'allais vous dire
il propose même que les républicains
puissent adhérer
alors tout va bien on n'en est pas là
d'accord avec emmanuel macron j'ai des
convergences puisse attendre de
divergences au chapitre convergence je
crois que la responsabilité de notre
génération
ça sera quand même de dépoussiérer
certain nombre de pratiques politiques
qui appartiennent au passé
un exemple très concret dont on a déjà
parlé avec emmanuel macron la séance des
questions d'actualité à l'assemblée
nationale espèce de théâtre de
marionnettes
où la gauche et la droite s'opposent de
manière absolument caricatural dans des
clivages qui sont caricaturaux ça je
pense qu'en termes de méthode il faut
par exemple sortir de ce genre de choses
mais il ya des divergences
je pense qu'on peut pas comme emmanuel
macron à la fois dire qu'on crée un
mouvement en marche et rester dans un
gouvernement qui est à l'arrêt voilà et
c'est une question que lui pose qu'est
ce qu'il fait dans un gouvernement où il
ya des dinosaures du parti socialiste
comme jean marc ayrault comme michel
sapin qu'est-ce qui fait dans un
gouvernement mais partie ce gouvernement
non il c'est à lui d'en juger mais voilà
je trouve qu'une petite incohérence à
être à la fois sans doute sincèrement
réformiste est en réalité de rester le
prisonnier volontaire d'un gouvernement
qui est complètement immobile
complètement sclérosé et qui n'avance
sur rien je trouve que là il ya un
contraste quand même qui l'interrogent
où cette initiative c'est donc un projet
sincère ou au contraire une manoeuvre
politique
non c'est un garçon intelligent qui a
des choses à apporter qui
voilà oxygène un peu le débat le débat
public je regarde ça avec une certaine
sympathie mais aussi avec beaucoup de
lucidité encore une fois je trouve qui
est un sujet de cohérence je trouve que
emmanuel macron peut difficilement
porter les idées qu'il porte
et puis en réalité s'arrêtait dès qu'on
lui demande de s'arrêter parce que dès
qu'il aimait une idée nouvelle un peu
opérationnels on lui dit de bien vouloir
rester silencieux sur la question du
temps de travail il a été complètement
cadenassé et sur plein d'autres sujets y
compris d'ailleurs sur ce qu'on appelle
la loi macron loi maquereau au bout du
bout qu'elle a libéralisé qu'il prenne
sa liberté
peut-être mais enfin c'est à lui d'en
juger en tout cas je pense aussi qu'il
faudra un moment qu'ils aillent devant
le suffrage universel jeu je le souhaite
pour lui pour les débats à l'assemblée
oui je trouve ça serait bien évidemment
savez c'est d'ailleurs une différence on
a à peu près de 100 km2 en termes de
formation le choix que j'ai fait moi
c'est d'aller d'abord nous frotter avec
les risques s'impliquer on verra dans
une monture et yoopa au devant le
suffrage universel je trouve que c'est
aussi ça il faut à la fois porter des
idées et ça il le fait il le fait bien
il faut être cohérent dans l'action ça
ne le fait pas très bien et puis il ya
un moment il faut aller je crois devant
devant devant les français devant les
gens pour pour pour se frotter au
suffrage universel direct et voir si on
a vraiment un mandat du peuple
alors on va passer sur une proposition
de loi que vous dont vous êtes à
l'origine c'est d'aider débattu cette
semaine au sénat elle vise à renforcer
le dialogue avec les clubs et les
supporters notamment de foot contre la
lutte sur le hooliganisme ce qui a donné
des idées d'ailleurs à aleksandar mots
notre célèbre micro trop tard
j'avais joué j'ai jamais joué demain non
il est même pas gonfler des pelles
oligan isme au sénat où il est au
courant c'est une bonne chose parce que
franchement quand on voit parfois la
violence qui se développe dans les
stades
vaut mieux éviter et les violences et
les bêtises avant lui redonner sa part à
vendre de formation générale ce soit
avant l'euro après l'euro moi je suis
pour le foot
le jeu de sport il supporters voulaient
que je joue au ballon avec vous vous
savez jouer au football un peu filles
entre la fifa je vais vous faire faire
une tête
méfiez-vous c'est un hooligan
qu'est ce que vous répondez aux
supporters qu'ils disent qu' il peut y
avoir des abus de l'atteinte à leur
liberté
on a fait en sorte de corriger la
proposition de loi qui pouvait
apparaître abusif puisque elle ne
parlait que de l'aspect répressif
quand on est un oubli gagnent pas
s'attendre à avoir quelques remarques
désagréables à son encontre et le gagner
mais c'est que dans le football c'est un
peu dans tous les sapins notre notre
sport tas pour l'instant les faits de
hooliganisme ans les a surtout vu dans
le football le volley ya pas de liga a
priori pas encore et va aller voir faut
vérifier faut toujours tout vérifier
il n'y a pas de ligue à dijon dans le
volley ball a priori non c'est tout ce
qu'ils ont quitté le football
volley-ball or voilà pour le micro tard
d'aleksandar mukete à la rencontre
notamment des volleyeurs c'est plutôt
calme le volet a priori notamment
corrigé l'aspect abusif et répressif a
dit le secrétaire d'état en charge des
sports thierry braillard
c'était vous ça abusif répressif c'était
dans votre texte
alors c'est une proposition de loi que
j'ai fait et vous a pas échappé que je
suis donc députés d'opposition
cette loi future loi l'arrivée elle
était votée à l'unanimité à l'assemblée
nationale à l'exception du front
national et des communes et donc c'est
plutôt pas si mal pas vraiment un échec
et j'ai compris qu effectivement en
commission les sénateurs ont également
donné un feu vert j'en suis très content
je supporters de l'aja ce soir j'irai au
match j'y amène à hauteur c'est un texte
je crois utile et puis tu es aveugle
comme mathieu agi à mais c'est assez
utile non c'est un texte qui est
également question l'utilité qu'est ce
qu'on fait ce don fait deux choses
d'abord on donne un peu plus de pouvoir
aux clubs de foot professionnel pour
éviter que des individus violents
viennent perturber la fête ça c'est un
volet de lutte contre les violences
et puis parallèlement on renforce ce
dialogue avec les supporters et
notamment aux demandes au club de
désigner un référent
voilà c'est un texte utile c'est pas un
texte va faire la révolution mais c'est
un texte qui complète un certain nombre
d'orientations et à quelques semaines de
l'euro 2016 on facilite aussi les
échanges de données avec l'uefa
bref c'est assez pratique ça a été pensé
avec des acteurs du monde sportif et il
ya eu le feu vert de manuel valls
bernard cazeneuve et l'unanimité des
parlementaires donc ses cannes à
l'arrivée on va rejoindre tout de suite
notre partenaire la loupe du scan s'est
tout de suite
jim j'ai assez bon meneur jean michaël
l'arrivée on va parler un peu de vous et
de nicolas sarkozy que vous connaissez
bien de le côtoyer depuis déjà plus de
dix ans je crois vous et que vous êtes
secrétaire général de l'association de
soutien à l'action de nicolas sarkozy
est ce que c'est correct je vous le
confirme ça s'appelle même d'ailleurs
maintenant la france pour la vie la
france pour la ville chez secrétaire
général de la france pour la vie à quoi
ça sert concrètement cette association
c'est une association qui a été créée
une déjà quinzaine d'années en réalité
et qui sait d'art organise un certain
nombre d'actions de soutien à
l'engagement qui est celui de nicolas
sarkozy au service de la france et
beltran scène également bien sûr c'est
une organisation qui s'organise comme
son nom l'indiqué pour soutenir l'action
de nicolas sarkozy et qui va monter en
puissance bien sûr dans dans les
semaines dans l'émoi préparer la
candidature de deux manières a causé
pour participer au débat public sous des
formes diverses mais je me sens très
impatients qui est non mais la question
qu'on se pose ces questions il peut
encore aujourd'hui empêcher une
candidature de nicolas sarkozy tout
semble être prêt pour
le décollage l'album vous confirme qu'il
vaut mieux être prêt avant qu'après ça
c'est déjà une information sérieuse
évidemment qu'il ya une préparation qui
est tout à fait nécessaire ensuite il
faut pas aller plus vite que la musique
il ya un temps pour tout je voudrais
rappeler que la primaire c'est en
novembre 2016
et aujourd'hui on est en avril
l'élection présidentielle avec la
primaire c'est désormais une élection à
4 tours il ya les deux tours de la
primaire il ya les deux tours de la
présidentielle il faut pas qu'on ajoute
un cinquième tour qui serait une espèce
de tour de manège des candidats à la
candidature en avril en met en jeu
actuellement je pense qu'il ya parfois
je le dis vraiment très directement je
pense qu'il ya peut-être un petit peu
trop de candidatures à la candidature
la primaire c'est pas l'organisation du
quart d'heure de gloire warholienne
c'est pas un happening permanent où
vient exposer son ego sont sa vie son
oeuvre
il s'agit de choisir le futur président
de la république française comme c'est
sérieux quel rôle souhaitez-vous aux
jouets côté nicolas sarkozy justement
dans cette aventure qui semble assez
bien parti je ne souhaite rien à ce que
je souhaite c'est le succès de la france
vraiment et je crois que je souhaite
complètement évidemment que nicolas
sarkozy s'engage encore plus activement
au service de la france dans l'est dans
les semaines ou dans les mois qui
viennent mais à titre personnel sur mon
rôle tout ça n'a strictement aucune
importance c'est pas ça qui compte la
france pour la vie fait pour être un
slogan la france pour la vie c'est déjà
le titre d'un livre qui se vend
extrêmement bien aux agressions qui
rencontre un succès un intérêt très très
fort dans tous les départements de
france a c'est déjà le titre d'un livre
car on l'a compris vous êtes donc un
fidèle de nicolas sarkozy et dans ces
cas là on se pose souvent la question
pour combien de temps combien de temps
ça va durer
il ya des ya des exemples je vous
réponds très directement gym jara c'est
j'essaie de me comporter
en officier loyal à son général éternel
mais fidélité c'est pas la fidélité du
chien fidèle fidélité c'est aussi le
renouveau la loyauté et le travail
ça fait aussi partie du tube du
renouveau je considère que nicolas
sarkozy a été un grand président de la
république qu'il est aujourd'hui comme
président des républicains qui fait un
job vraiment de de très bonne tenue pour
pour organiser pour préparer le projet
et puis je souhaite vraiment qu'ils
puissent continuer à continuer à servir
le pays parce que il a plein d'atouts
pour ça il a de l'imagination il a une
vraie connexion à la fois sur la réalité
dit les français au quotidien et sur des
enjeux internationaux bref je pense
qu'il est tout à fait adaptée à la
situation pourquoi je vous pose la
question parce qu'un certain nombre de
jeunes pousses sarkozyste je pense
notamment par exemple à gérald darmanin
je pense peut-être aussi à geoffroy
didier qui vient de d'annoncer sa
candidature et qui dit quoi qu'il arrive
si nicolas sarkozy est candidat je reste
candidat jeu je défendrai mon projet
face à lui et ses jeunes tous ont pris
leurs distances au fil des années avec
ecône impossible ils font ce qu'ils ne
sera pas votre cas moi je travaille ou
donnés dans les dix personnages mamade
en trois vers hadji je considère encore
une fois que la loyauté ça compte je
travaille dans cette équipe j'ai 39 ans
donc je pas non plus quand même je
voudrais garde donc dance wii et so what
if et il fait ce qu'il veut ça n'a
aucune importance personne n'imagine
seule seconde que la personne que vous
évoquez sera présenté en république
française en 2010 est je pense donc tout
ça n'a aucune à tort selon vous de de
défendre sa candidature ne m'intéressant
à un personnage sa candidature ne
m'intéresse pas j'ai mes rêves le médium
n'a pas aujourd'hui vraiment d'intérêt
ce qui compte c'est de savoir qui sera
présent la république en 2017 qui va
prendre les mesures utiles dire dès 2017
pour la france on va regarder une
séquence houleuse qui s'est déroulée
mercredi sur le plateau de lcp
vous étiez face aux députés ps
d'argenteuil philippe doucet qui
apparemment a pas vraiment apprécié vous
compariez la commune d'argenteuil a
molenbeek français on écoute surtout la
loi à terre donnant le tuer la promotion
les américains me de votre fachos bien
non pardon à chaud et ont donc demandé
aux répondants de tribunaux vous avez
porté plainte
guillaume larrivé à une autre époque à
une autre époque j'aurais proposé ce
député assez obscur d'ailleurs je vais
proposer du halal duels mais j'avais
beaucoup j'ai fait beaucoup des scream à
l'époque de sciences clos il ya une
vingtaine d'années malheureusement
malheureusement on peut plus faire de
deux gants blancs non mais je trouve ça
lamentable sur le sur le framework of
the permettait d'avoir un minimum de
réflexion juridique pour préparer de
manière bien rédiger ce qui ce qui doit
être fait mais au-delà de ça sur le fond
ce que j'ai voulu dénoncer dans cet
échange très vif ces espèces de deals
communautariste entre un certain nombre
d'élus socialistes et un certain nombre
de réseaux islamistes
ça c'est une réalité il ya des petits
arrangements communautaire qui doivent
être dénoncés et qui participe de ce qu
elisabeth badinter a appelé très
justement le gaucho islamisme ou
l'islamo gauchisme c'est un vrai
problème et ça il faut l'affronter de
près cette réalité alors le même si ça
dérange le le maire d'argenteuil qui est
qui appartient votre parti républicain
georges mothron il est également monté
au créneau sur ce sujet après votre
votre sortie sur justement cette commune
de d'argentât il l'a dit guillaume
larrivé il connaît pas le terrain il
fait partie des cabinets qu'est ce que
vous lui répondez jurés donc que je suis
député pas l'huile était battu voilà
mais on met tout ça tout ça n'est pas ça
n'est pas très intéressant pardon les
français qui vivent à trappes
les français qui vivent à sevran les
français qui vivent dans un certain
nombre de quartiers de villes de france
ils savent très bien quelle est la
réalité qu'ils subissent et donc pardon
même si ça dérange certains petits
notables qui sont pas contents il faut
dire la vérité surtout faut l'affronter
vous avez là et je dénonce je dénonce et
moi ces arrangements communautariste
portable merci merci merci merci à tous
de nous avoir suivis très bonne semaine
on se retrouve évidemment
prochaine katia 13,6 de programmes sur
lcp public sénat